ahora comenzamos con un tema
completamente nuevo del análisis de
circuitos llamado estado estacionario
senoidal también podemos llamarlo
análisis se ha se ha significa corriente
alterna y significa que es un voltaje o
una corriente en donde la señal cambia
de signos a veces es positiva o a veces
es negativa y la convención es sé a
corriente alterna lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es dar una revisión rápida
de cómo es resolver una ecuación como la
que vemos aquí este es un circuito r lc
y veremos cómo sería resolver esto
usando ecuaciones diferenciales lo cual
va a implicar mucho trabajo y aquí vamos
a presentar un nuevo método de análisis
al que nos vamos a referir como estado
estacionario senoidal es una
transformación que vamos a realizar en
este circuito que al final nos dará una
gran recompensa vamos a ver cuál será la
recompensa y cómo lucirá al final
después veremos algo de las matemáticas
que tenemos que revisar para
comprender completamente esta
transformación
este cambio de punto de vista primero
veamos este circuito es un circuito con
alimentación tipo l rc aquí está la
función de alimentación es un voltaje de
entrada que tiene una forma senoidal y
está alimentando una secuencia de un
inductor una resistencia y un capacitor
en un vídeo anterior vimos la respuesta
natural de este circuito y para hacerlo
hicimos un cortocircuito aquí quitamos
la fuente e hicimos un cortocircuito y
agregamos un poco de energía al circuito
y vimos lo que hacía por sí solo su
respuesta natural ahora mejoramos esto
le agregamos una fuente de energía y
tenemos que resolver de nuevo esto ahora
incluyendo esta fuente si usamos la
técnica de ecuaciones diferenciales
sería más o menos así el primer paso en
un análisis de circuitos de este tipo es
escribir una ecuación l beckham o ley de
voltajes de kickoff en donde queremos
encontrar esta corriente de aquí
lo que es nuestra variable independiente
así que si ustedes recuerdan lo que
hicimos para la respuesta natural
terminamos con una ecuación diferencial
que luce así l por la segunda derivada
de i con respecto al tiempo más
r por la primera derivada de i + 1 en 13
x y cada uno de estos términos
individuales representa un voltaje el
voltaje a través del inductor a través
de la resistencia y a través del
capacitor así que es el voltaje del
inductor el voltaje de la resistencia y
el voltaje del capacitor y si sumamos
todos estos nos tiene que dar el voltaje
de entrada así que esta es una ecuación
forzada lo que quiere decir que esta es
la función de entrada forzada como
resolvemos esto las matemáticas para
resolver esto son bastante difíciles de
por si nos fue difícil resolver la
respuesta natural y si agregamos esto va
a requerir todavía más trabajo así que
como hicimos anteriormente lo que ahora
vamos a hacer es proponer una solución
y la solución como ya hemos hecho
anteriormente y ya se nos ha vuelto
hábito es que esto sea igual a una
constante por y elevada a cierta
frecuencia natural por t así que a por
el ala ese porte es nuestra solución
propuesta para y como función del tiempo
ese es un término de frecuencia
recuerden que ese porte no deben de
tener unidades por lo que ese tiene
unidades de 1 entre el tiempo o lo que
es lo mismo la frecuencia así que a esto
le llamamos la frecuencia natural y
cuando ponemos y la forma de saber si es
una solución es poniendo esto dentro de
esta ecuación y nos debe de dar una
ecuación que luce así después de
factorizar y terminamos con l por s al
cuadrado más r por s más 1 en 13 y todo
esto es igual para la respuesta natural
a 0
y resolvemos esta ecuación haciendo este
término de aquí igual a cero y
despejamos ese para saber cuál es la
frecuencia natural y luego regresamos y
encontramos a al ver las condiciones
iniciales de aquí cualquiera que sea la
energía inicial aquí va a determinar el
valor de a el siguiente paso en esta
respuesta forzada en la que tenemos al
voltaje de entrada alimentando al
circuito es que tenemos que igualar esto
al voltaje de entrada y despejar la
respuesta forzada
si dejamos que el voltaje de entrada sea
cualquier función que se nos ocurra
cualquier forma de onda esto va a ser
muy difícil de resolver matemáticamente
nos va a llevar mucho tiempo a hacerlo y
básicamente no quiero hacerlo así que
veamos de qué otra manera podemos
resolver estas ecuaciones y podemos
simplificar este proceso si ponemos
cierto límite aquí en que puede ser el
voltaje de entrada y si nos limitamos a
que el voltaje de entrada sean solamente
senoidal es querrá decir que el voltaje
de entrada tendrá la forma de un coseno
de omega t más fi en donde sí es cierto
ángulo o que puede tomar la forma de
seno de omega t más fi cualquier onda
que tenga estas formas se les llama
senoidal es o también se les llama
sinusoidales senoidal es o sinusoidales
es el nombre general que se le da a
estas funciones oa estas curvas
seno y cosenos y ya que no queremos que
estas matemáticas nos exploten en el
rostro la entrada general aquí vamos a
desarrollar una forma bastante elegante
de resolver circuitos a limitarnos a
entradas sinusoidales o senoidal es
hasta aquí terminamos y continuaremos en
el siguiente vídeo donde presentaremos
la idea de análisis senoidal